vil characters and games the talented
artists and animators at Crystal
Dynamics have built Lara from the ground
up to realize this vision part of
creating the most realistic character
that we possibly can are things like
details now so pores on the skin we're
talking about eyelashes down to finite
things where snowflakes would land on
that eyelash I think the things that
really get into the nitty-gritty of what
makes something feel very tangible it
gets a lot of character those are the
things that were able to do now there's
a first read which is Laura's main
silhouette we want that secondary we
want to get in there really tight and be
able to see all those little tiny things
that make her very very unique it's the
imperfections even so scars from the
last game have been transported over to
the new one we want to show character
and progression of time and show that
she's gone through some things to get
here we first started with skins and we
used that data to get make sure the
proportions were right that whole logic
was right and their clothes and then we
added our artistic touch to it and we
added a whole lot of details too so you
can actually look at her skin you'll see
pores you look at the clothes you see
all that micro details on the clothes so
we added a lot to that to make her come
to life whenever if she gets into a
fight she can get dirty or she can get
bloody but she's out in the snow she'll
actually accumulate snow on her clothes
so she fits into every environment that
she's in we're able to actually capture
the nuances of facial movement and she
really comes to life and it is so much
better than the bone driven system that
I used in the past and this all adds to
the realism of her acting
you
a crystal we look at every granular
detail from her Anatomy to her garments
to her motion in order to deliver a
believable and lifelike Lara Croft these
goals become a reality as we see Lara
navigate the mysterious catacombs of the
prophets too
Oh